me reviewing Dolphin Tale I couldn't
called that but here I am so here it is
Dolphin Tale so I really didn't know
much about Dolphin Tale I mean I just
saw the poster and I was like ah movie
with Morgan Freeman that's cool although
I don't know if it means much anymore I
mean he did do the voiceover and Conan
the Barbarian so I don't know alright so
dolphin tells the story of a kid you
know he's a loner kid he's a daydreamer
he doesn't really like school he's in
summer school actually reminds me of me
in high school
and he comes across a dolphin on a beach
his tail is wrapped up in rope and so
the dolphin gets taken away to this
rehabilitation center run by Harry
Connick jr. and then the kids bonding
with this dolphin and that's our movie
now it sounds really cheesy and in parts
it kind of is I mean it's really
heartfelt movie and they do the
heartfelt stuff really well it's a
really good family movie but there are
parts where you're like this is one of
those hallmark movies I don't know if
I'm supposed to enjoy this yet I kind of
do and there's nothing wrong we said I'm
letting you know right now if you watch
Dolphin Tale and you have that feeling
where you're like oh that's really nice
they're not weird it's okay your friends
will give you crap for it but I'm just
saying it's alright just tell them hey
Jeremy said it's alright and Morgan
Freeman's role in this movie when I saw
most like okay here's what happens this
movie takes place after the Dark Knight
Rises in the Dark Knight Rises Batman's
gonna get his back broken Wayne
Enterprises stock is gonna drop they're
gonna have to sell the company the
company's gonna be gone Lucius Fox is
gonna be out of a job in which he now is
in dolphin town his character is exactly
that I swear and he's really good in the
movies Morgan Freeman I can't be like
yeah Morgan Freeman he was the weak link
right there cuz it probably won't happen
ever and what I like about Dolphin Tale
is although it concentrates on this
dolphin having to adapt and survive
because it loses its tail it does a good
job at linking that to human beings
about how they have to survive and
overcome obstacles it was just really
true and it's an important message I
like that doesn't change the fact that
sometimes you like all Mark movie I'm
just saying however you can take the
most jaded human being on earth and by
the end of this movie if they're still
like oh no it's just stupid they
officially hate people who conquer
obstacles and hardships and they hate
kids and dolphins which who doesn't hate
kids these days but dolphins they're
alright and dolphin tales based on the
true story I didn't know that so the
fact is based on the true story like
cuts back on the cheese factor and which
amps up though oh wow that's really cool
factor one of the coolest parts is the
end credits it shows real footage of all
the stuff happening that you just saw
but like you know real and the movie
actually had it pretty true to form this
stuff really happened so that was
awesome right there in the end I'll say
it's a good time
no alcohol required in a really strong
family movie kind of way like if you're
playing Gears of War right now and
you're just shredding through everybody
I don't expect you to put down the
controller and be like dudes I'll be
back
I'm watching Dolphin Tale it's just not
realistic however it has my stamp of
approval as a really good family movie
and so what can I ask you about a movie
like what's your favorite dolphin movie
I'm not going to do that in any case if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more